hi this is dr gregory sadler
i'm a professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason i o
where we put philosophy into practice
i've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years
and i find that many people run into
difficulties reading classic
philosophical texts
sometimes it's the way things are said
or how the text is structured
but the concepts themselves are not
always that complicated and that's where
i come in
to help students and lifelong learners
i've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube
many viewers say they find them useful
what you're currently watching is part
of a new series of shorter videos
each of them focused on one core concept
from an important philosophical text
i hope you find it useful as well
towards the end of technologies of the
self michel foucault shifts his
attention to
christianity and he makes a couple very
useful points his his treatment
we shouldn't look at it as meant to be
an adequate explanation of what's going
on
in the the shift to christian culture uh
per se but rather
as providing some interesting
illumination because clearly as
an account of what's going on in the
first couple centuries
it's um you know it's rather selective
and
inadequate so he tells us that he wants
to look at this
transition from pagan to christian
culture
you notice that one of the things that's
going to come up in this that's of
significant interest
is how stoic technologies
of the self or modes of care of the self
things that were arguably not just stoic
but the stoics were sort of leading the
charge in that
got transformed and incorporated in a
different context
to become something quite different
almost
in some respects unrecognizable
from their their original uh forms
and he points out a couple important
aspects of
christianity again not totally unique to
christianity
in some respects when we look at
religions um
particularly if we're thinking about
misty religions in the ancient world
so he tells us that i wish to examine
the scheme of one of the main
main techniques of the self in early
christianity and what it was
as a truth game so there's clear-cut
continuities and discontinuities in the
transition from pagan to christian
culture christianity belongs to the
salvation religions it's one of those
religions which is supposed to lead the
individual from one reality to another
from death to life from time to eternity
again not totally unique even in the
mediterranean
and near east since you have also
mystery religions
you know going on as well in order to
achieve this christianity impose a set
of conditions
and rules of behavior for a certain
transformation of the self this is
really key
he says it's not only a salvation
religion so that's one thing that would
include it with like say buddhism
and you know zoe astrid as um right
it's also a confessional religion it
imposes very strict
obligations of truth dogma and canon
more so than do the pagan religions
truth obligations to believe this or
that were and are still very numerous
the duty to accept a set of obligations
to hold certain books as a permanent
truth
to accept authoritarian decisions and
matters of truth
not only to believe certain things but
to show that one believes to accept
institutional authority
all characteristic of christianity not
exclusively characteristic of
christianity
but certainly playing a role and
something
representing a kind of new attitude
towards things now how
how strict is this if we are it depends
on which christian we're looking at if
we're looking at
cassian we get one point of view if
we're looking at clement of alexandria
we get another point of view
we're looking at tertullian we get
another point of view so we'll
we'll put that we'll bracket that that
issue for a moment
so what are these obligations there's
truth obligations and
some of these are obligations about
belief
right some of them he says are also
obligations about action you have to do
things in a certain way
and some are authority and then there's
another set of obligations and this is
where
foucault is really interested he says
that
christianity requires another form of
truth obligation different from
faith each person has the duty to know
who he is
that is to try to know what is happening
inside him
to acknowledge faults to recognize
temptations to locate desires
everyone is obligated to disclose these
things either to god or to others in the
community
and hence to bear public or private
witness against himself
truth obligations of faith and the self
are linked together
the link permits a purification of the
soul impossible
without self knowledge so again we see
the you know care of the self
and self knowledge but now they're being
configured
in a way that's different than say pagan
philosophies
or even you know what's left of pagan
religion
at the time so there's an obligation to
know the truth of the self and foucault
isolates out two main ways of doing this
now
here's where we have to ask are these
the only ways that early christians and
like say the first five centuries of
christianity
we're making sense of these things
definitely not i mean he even talks
about
uh chrysostom as you know providing an
example of something that that's
different when it comes to
self-examination so these are things
that he's isolating out as sort of
main developments but don't don't assume
that they apply to every single
christian author
or every single christian practitioner
at the time
it's a little bit more complex than that
and so he identifies if we jump to the
very end
two main new technologies
of the self and he uses the greek terms
for these
exomologasis and x agariosis
so exomologasis is as he's going to say
at the end
um dramatic expression of the situation
of the penitent as sinner which makes
manifest his status as sinner right so
what does that mean there's some way in
which the the
sinner the self is saying i am
a sinner i am penitent i recognize the
wrongness
of this i'm going to do something about
it i'm gonna make my
myself commit to things and thereby the
sin is going to be
not not just brought forth but also
dealt with in in important ways and it's
done
in dramatic manner meaning there is a
narrative
and it's being done in relation to other
people or
internalized within the self exaggerosis
he says an analytical
and continual verbalization of thoughts
carried out in the relation of complete
obedience to someone else
this relation modeled on the
renunciation of one's own will and one's
own self now
that's that's a bit of a
ideal there rather than a practice the
continual
verbalization of thoughts if there was
the continual verbalization of thoughts
the way
foucault depicts it then we would have a
must vas much vaster
monastic and confessional literature
than we do
and monks would never be able to get
anything else done right
um and and so you know we have to be a
little bit skeptical
of this but the verbalization of
thoughts the examination of what's going
on
in relation to obedience to a superior
well ultimately
all the way up to you know the god
as as the ultimate superior so
or you could say god the trinity the
saints you know whatever it is that we
want to conceive of it
including uh saint benedict one of the
very important early
monastic writers and he says there's a
great difference between
exomologasis and hexagoniosis but we
have to underscore the fact there's one
important element in common you cannot
disclose
without renouncing so you
disclose and renounce you renounce by
disclosing there's a
certain dialectical relationship there
you disclose who you are
you also renounce who you are in in the
hopes that you can become a better who
you
are as a result so let's talk about
exomologasis
what foucault has to say about this in
particular
he tells us that this involves
recognizing the
the self as a sinner and as
a penitent exomologasis is recognition
of fact recognition of
of who you are what you are so it has a
penitential meaning
you are seeking penance you you announce
to somebody it could be the bishop could
be the the community
that you are a sinner and then you do
penance for quite a while
you're you're not you're not you're not
just going to confession and then say
say you know 15 hail mary's and try not
to do this stuff again no it's years and
years and years
of quite public in some respects
demonstrations right like he says
the sinner seeks his penance he visits
the bishop asks the bishop to impose on
him the status of the penitent
he must explain why he wants the status
he must explain his faults
it's an explanation of his status
so you know tertullian talks about
people wearing
hair shirts and ashes standing humbled
before the church
prostatin oneself kissing the brethren's
knees it's not just a verbal behavior
it's a dramatic recognition of one's own
status and he says
it also designates the entire process
that the penance
penitent experiences in the status over
the years
they are engaging in self-punishment as
well as self-revelation the acts by
which
he punishes himself are
indistinguishable
by from the acts by which he reveals
himself
and so it's not nominal but as he says
theatrical
tertullian uh uses this term publicatio
sui to characterize it and foucault
points out this is related to seneca's
daily self-examination
but for seneca it doesn't imply verbal
analysis of deeds or thoughts it's only
a somatic and symbolic expression
what was private for the stoics was
public for the christians
he says what was the functions of this
well by publicizing your
sins you in some way wipe them out
you restore the purity acquired by
baptism it also
shows the sinner as they are so this is
the paradox
it rubs out the sin yet reveals the
sinner
and then he asks well why would showing
forth a face the sins
here's where we get three interesting
models that he brings up
one of which is a medical model you show
your sins
like you you know you take your shirt
off and you show the sores
so the doctor can heal you right so
that's that's one
way another is as he says less frequent
the tribunal model
you appease your judge by confessing
faults
so the sinner plays devil's advocate as
will the devil on the day of judgment
and then he says the most important
model to explain exomologasis
is the model of death torture or
martyrdom the theories and practices of
penitence
are elaborated around the problem of the
person who prefers to die
rather than to compromise or abandon the
faith and he doesn't bring this up but
really what this amounts to is kind of a
split within the self of
you know i am turning against my my
sins which threaten to you know bring me
down to death i'm going to
in some way testify to the fact that i'm
not just
the sum of my sins and their their
effects so those are
three models and so foucault says that
this is a
very important early christian
uh technology of the self to understand
the self as the sinning penitent and
perhaps to be redeemed
self and then there's ex agaroses
says during the fourth century we find a
much a very different technology for
disclosure of the self
this one is reminiscent of the
verbalizing exercises
in relation of to a teacher master of
the pagan philosophical schools and we
can see the transfer of several stoic
techniques
of the self to christian spiritual
techniques
and this is where again he brings up
chris system and he says okay so we're
going to put him aside
and this should tell us right here that
well if we expand our purview of the
early christian literature
this might not bear out exactly what
foucault is telling us here
he goes on and he says the
well-developed and elaborate
practice of the self-examination in
monastic christianity is what we're
talking about
here and there's two main aspects to
this
obedience and contemplation now
i want to take a pause here the main
person that he's bringing up is john
cassian
and john cassian is a very important
author for
early christian monasticism
what we want to keep in mind is that
cassian
and a friend of his are from the west
and then they travel to palestine to
find out how
people are doing monasticism there why
do they do that because monasticism in
the west is really not
that big of a thing at this point in
time and it's
you know it's viewed that the
palestinians
have got it down better they've got
better techniques they have more to
offer
the palestinians then tell him oh
you know where you really want to go is
egypt because they're the ones who
really do the stuff go out in the desert
with
the monks there and you know interview
the abbotts and see what they have to
say
and john cassian produces the two most
important works
are the the institutes and the uh
conferences or conversations right the
institute is a very systematic work
about what monasticism ought to look
like as
much of it is spent on analysis and
prescriptions about the eight capital
vices that later on become the seven
deadly sins
foucault doesn't mention that at all
here uh there's also some other
important things and then there's the
conversations with the abbots about a
whole range
of different things and and so foucault
is getting some of this
out of there but there's other you know
there's other monastic literature that's
talking about obedience as well
so he says here we go obedience has a
very different character and monastic
life
um it must bear on all aspects of the
monk's life
there's no element of the life of the
monk which may escape from this
fundamental
and permanent relation of total
obedience to the master
who's the master in this case probably
the prior the abbot you know somebody
else
and he goes on and he says cassian
repeats an old principle from the
oriental tradition
everything the monk does without
permission of his master constitutes a
theft obedience is complete control of
behavior by the master
not a final autonomous state it is a
sacrifice of the self of the subject's
own will this is the new technology of
the
self okay so there's you know this is
largely correct uh for further reading
of monastic literature would
reveal there's a lot more to it than
that
but you know let's let's go on the
second feature of monastic life is that
contemplation is considered the supreme
good contemplation of what contemplation
of god
which can only really happen if you're
contemplating is coming from a pure
heart so you have to
figure out what your sins are and and
also
figure out where the instabilities lie
within your conscience
or consciousness and this is where you
know cassian's eight
principal vices which were originally
evagrious ponticus's
eight thoughts can come in right you
might be distracted by
um vainglory or gluttony or
wrath or acadia you know this
restlessness or
sadness those those are problems and so
he says that the technology of
self-examination dominated by obedience
and contemplation becomes much more
concerned with thought
than action seneca places stress on
action with cassian the object is not
past actions of the day it's your
present thoughts
because the monk must continuously turn
his thoughts to god
he must scrutinize the actual course of
this
thought and so the scrutiny of
conscience consists in trying to
immobilize consciousness to eliminate
movements of the spirit
which divert one from god cope presents
us in a very static way
and he talks about a couple different
metaphors that the cassian has
the analogy of the mill thoughts are
like grains we want to have the right
grains
military analogies officer ordering good
soldiers who march to the right bad to
the left
and then the analogy of a money changer
you have to examine
coins their effigy their metal where
they came from and this is this is all
quite true
cassian has many more images than these
if you actually
read through his works and so you might
say why why these
in particular because they they fit you
know the the narrative that foucault
is is telling us here so we do have you
know new christian technologies
of the self that are developing um
there's more you know much more that
could be said about this this is what
foucault
here has to say about this transition
from pagan to christian culture
and these new or you could call them you
know revised
technologies of the self that are coming
onto the scene and becoming part of
at least a portion of the west western
consciousness
you